among screenwriters what a lot of new
writers don't get is that the
frustration that they're experiencing it
never goes away that's the way it
operates at the highest levels for the
most successful practitioners you don't
need to be a tenured college professor
to know that it's better to be rich than
poor but and of course to be a wealthy
successful writer is better than being a
an impoverished unsuccessful one but
both of those non successful one and the
very successful wealthy one will be will
have the same frustration the same
disappointment the same issues involving
fulfillment it ain't easy for anybody
sure and the and the insurance salesmen
that yearns to write but doesn't because
he wants to keep a mortgage and his kids
in school that would probably be more of
a frustration because well you know
there's no reason that that insurance
salesman can't write if he really if
it's important to him to write he can
write he can't sit down at at the desk I
I'm very privileged I have my duties
here on campus but I have many days that
I don't have to come in at all and I
work out of my office at home where I
write and I can just write the whole day
but I don't write the whole day I write
over two or three hours there's no
reason that salesmen can't set aside an
hour to write he's just gonna go more
slowly I like to tell writers imagine
you're saying you don't have enough time
to write nobody has enough time to write
Stephen King doesn't have enough time to
write there's not a writer who will tell
you she he has enough time to write yet
supposing you went to bed an hour later
every night that would liberate two
months of writing time I'm not I'm
talking about not around the clock but
just a 40-hour five-day week you would
get if you had another 365 hours
available which is what you'd have if
you went to sleep and
hour later every night that would give
me two months to write in the year that
you that you haven't used yet in
addition to whatever else else you're
doing now couldn't you get maybe you
couldn't write a screenplay in two
months although maybe you could our
students here have to in ten weeks but
you could certainly write a big chunk of
it well supposing you say well I I
already go to bed too late I can't go to
bed an hour later well why don't I go to
bed
15 minutes later get up 15 minutes
earlier couldn't you manage that that
would if you could do that over a year
that would give you a month of writing
time so you do have the time the problem
is you don't have the will you're up
against what I think his name is Stephen
Pressler there's a book called the the
art of the war of art it's a play on the
art of war and it's a pamphlet it's a
very light piece you could read it while
you're waiting for the light to change
but it's brilliant it is brilliant and
what pressor talks about boy I hope I'm
getting the name rights Pressfield thank
you thank you Stephen Pressfield
Pressfield
what he calls it as resistance that
there's this resistance sitting there
and you just have to face it you have to
do it
and you have to stop trying to like it
somebody was telling people a client of
mine when I say client I mean a writer
whom I'm giving notes to on a script
what he's giving me is a lot a lot a lot
of money I mean I charge a big fees to
do this it takes me away from my own my
own work I love to get this kind of work
even better not to get it but the the
point is this guy was writing back to me
he's just about ready now to start the
he's gone over the notes he's thought
everything through and he's about to
start the actual rewrite and he's just
miserable contemplating actually getting
into the rewrite and I said to him I'm
glad to hear it you why am I glad to
hear that he's misery
because he's it tells me that he's
having the experiences that a real
writer would have only an amateur
Pressfield would would put it this way
only an amateur would imagine that would
say that she or he can't wait to get
into the rewrite is delighted
contemplating getting up in the morning
and working on that script the contrary
is the case dreading it I have a guest
in my class a very famous writer that's
we you know we were in the Hollywood
community here and we were a pretty
prestige operation and lots of really I
mean I had Neil Simon come in here and
talk about comedy we've had 30 years ago
Tennessee Williams come in and speak I
mean you know that's like being in
seminary and having a Q&A with God you
know so there was a very famous writer
and very successful but admired writer
in my in my class and I gave him a copy
of my screenwriting book and he just as
a little present to you know thanking
him for their coming in and he got in
touch with me a few days later and he
said he thought that um coals to
Newcastle what is he going to do with a
screenwriting book he's a very well
established writer and that was pretty
arrogant of me to give him this book he
said nevertheless he opened up the book
of one of my first principles is that
the real writers hate to write all
writers who were serious writers they
don't like to write we love having
written but actually writing is always
painful isn't good enough I thought
yesterday when it was Mountain rereading
it and it's not as good so and I'm very
very frustrating do I dare show this to
anybody how can I expect people to in
exchange for this give me money so I can
put out you know author Don John my
children's teeth and so on
this guy said to me it was such a
liberation to read for him to read that
that alright okay to write and to
discover that he's not the the only one
who doesn't leap from his bed in the
morning you know with bells on eager
beyond description to get into his
writing we
want to put it off delay it defer it
it's that way for everybody
you